Thanksgiving is different now.
It's an old thing. It's as old as America
and older than that. George Washington
did a Thanksgiving Proclamation.
Lincoln did a famous one 100 years later.
Traditionally it descends from the
harvest festival which is a seasonal
thing.
So you spend the summer
getting in the crops, praying for rain or
less rain, it's never the farmers think
it's never the right amount of rain.
And then you have the hectic thing of
getting the crops in, which is night and
day labor and exhausting, and then you've
got the crops, and that's something to
celebrate.
Life doesn't work that way anymore.
It isn't seasonal,
in the same way.
So I think we have to make an effort to
make it seasonal,
and there's many ways to do that. The
College is actually in the business of
recalling things that are beyond time.
Things that are not just seasonal, things
that are eternal because you know at the
end of the season, Thanksgiving is when
you think about
gratitude to the eternal for the fact
that you've got food to eat,
and for the chance to do the labor to
produce it.
We can get the cooperation from nature
that it takes to produce it.
And we're grateful for that and there's
a natural time to stop and be grateful. I
think music is a great and powerful way
to go about that.
Music is a big thing here. I sit in here
here in our Chapel, it's being prepared
right now for a Christmas video that
you'll have access to pretty soon
by our new Sacred Music choir. I think
you're going to see that they're
wonderful.
What is the music that they sing?
It's about the eternal, and music has an
unusual power to transport.
And Plato's Republic along with
gymnastic, which is things you do to your
body, to make it better, it is the most
powerful of two powerful things.
Music in Plato’s Republic includes
literature and poetry and all forms of
art that can affect the mind and the
senses and the emotions,
and so, music is very important.
This morning I started listening to one
of my favorite pieces of music—Fauré's
Requiem.
It's 35 minutes long. It's very
beautiful.
The third movement is called Sanctus and
that comes from “sacred” and that word
“sacred” has meant the same thing in Latin
and all the other languages where it
appears. It means “touching.” They're
connected to the Divine. The holiday
season, which begins and includes
Thanksgiving and runs through the
wonderful thing of Christmas,
is a great time to celebrate the eternal.
We have to remember to stop and do that
because
if we don't remember the eternal, our
temporal work, our work in time, won't be
meaningful or well directed. Our College
is in the business of remembering the
sublime
because that is the end of life, and the
only guide to life that will work.
In this troubled time, and it's very
troubled, I worry about these times a
great deal,
and then I remember the Sanctus, and I
remember that sooner or later, all will
be well.
Happy Thanksgiving.